hey guys this is Pete peppers and I'm
going to go over some of the power-ups
in the new game scrubby dubby saga so
this is a regular straight line laughter
there it's um it just explodes in a way
that it's facing and this is how you
make it match for together and when you
match for horizontal soaps you get a
vertical shooting line laughter and when
you match for vertical soaps you get a
horizontal shooting line blaster which
you can see there there's another
vertical one and you can see will we can
make a another one and then we can match
those two together like that and we get
a bigger one that shoots both vertical
and horizontally so that's a that's a
powerful one so now we'll look at some
of the different ones that we can make
there's really only a few we have this
is a this is a super line blaster like
horizontal one and that comes from
matching the square blaster the puffer
fish like the one up here on the right
and see how that clears out a square you
match one of those together with a
horizontal line blaster and you get one
that will shoot three lines at the same
time same thing goes when you get here's
a how you make the puffer square blaster
right there and then if we combine this
with something else we get a bigger
special so that's a it's obviously a
good thing to do whenever you can
now we can match the the square with the
vertical line blaster on the left and
now this will shoot three lines up and
down you can see the stripe on it coming
in the case where it goes so that's pout
you know do you make one and then you
connect it with another and a combo and
then you get an extra powerful one so
you can see that when you Kaskade you
can make them too so you want to clear
out the board and have lots of space
where they can fall so you can do that
too and then finally the last one would
be when you mix or when you match two of
these buffers together and move it
around a little bit and then we put them
together and then we get the big poppa
right here and this blows up a giant
square you see that there it's like five
squares by five squares instead of just
three squares by three squares like the
other one there's another up and down
one and that's pretty much it they they
come in handy in different ways on
different ones but that's how each of
them are made and how the combos work
once you put them together hopefully
this will clear any questions you have
out about that but if you have any more
feel free to leave comments below and
we'll I'll get to them and answer them
as soon as I can let me know what you
think about scrubby dubby saga and make
sure you like this video if you found it
helpful and you subscribe to our channel
to get more videos in the future thanks